je pars odile je pars sans me retourner
non pas poil au nez le d'esclaves pas
jeu par odile tu pouf et bien pouf pouf
tu ne me crois pas mais je m'en vais
comme dit si bien verlaine au vent
mauvais plait-il odile mais quelle
explication il n'y a rien
d'extraordinaire
j'ai besoin de son souffle rauque sur ma
nuque embrasé pantalon
j'ai besoin de ses mains à la recherche
de sonorités nouvelles sur le clavier de
mais sans se dire j'y pensais encore ce
matin mon bureau crédit lyonnais
tout ce que je demande c'est de courir
nu sous une pluie fine sur la falaise
avec des grands chais mouillé c'est
pourtant simple vu qu'on s'abattent en
rien dans un champ de blé mûr avec
avenir de vivaldi qui me tourner la tête
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise non
je ne renie pas le passé mais l'avenir
adele c'est sa jambe gauche quand elles
passent derrière mon dos pour que son
orteil touche mon oreille pendant encore
à 100% droite contourne son genou et
vient s'enrouler autour de ce modèle
est-ce qu'il faut te faire un dessin
odile assaillent et le bureau des pleurs
maintenant mais il ne s'agit pas de
savoir si ça bouge en brasse
techniquement mieux
- bien que la tienne bon ses pieds sont
plus grands et alors ce n'est pas un
concours c'est une histoire comme il y
en a tous les jours je laime c'est tout
c'est classique et lui aussi il même
c'est la vie ça qu'est ce qui étonne
odile
je suis méchant moi je mets chants jeux
michon garçons le docteur m'a dit quel
âge tu as
j'ai 40 ans oh mais tu es grand oui je
suis grand je baby boom j'aime pas les
petites filles j'ai dis à la petite
fille le père noël du docteur m'a
demandé tu n'aimes pas cette petite
fille entends-tu et son papa oui je suis
son papa qu'est ce qui est arrivé
pourtant que tu es été à l'école oui
école nationale d'administration
ena et tu te souviens de ce qu'on a
appris et non tu te souviens de la
chanson la veille les chansons que tu
chantais la situation économique dans
l'industrie nationale est préoccupant
que j'aime pas jusqu'à je ne partirai
que j'aime papunya je passe par le
docteur maudit chers amis c'est de la
régression infantile et gression a senti
le
q le numéro un ce soir c'est moi le
numéro un je suis la belette numéro un
il ya toute la france qui me regardent
pour ce faire la france
ça va vous moi ça va c'est dur en ce
moment ça va aller ça allait on vous l'a
dit à la publicité
en france on n'a pas de pétrole mais on
a des idées ça ira ça ira ça ira je me
disais à l'industriel bien connu à son
chauffeur
mon nom eût refusé une augmentation
croyez-moi lucien c'est pas nous est
plus à plaindre c'est pas nous c'est pas
nous ah lalala lalala tous ces pays qui
crèvent de faim c'est pas du possible
c'est pas possible ça va péter
partout les chinois les indiens les
africains dans ce nouveau nom goisses
j avec un point bien j'en sais plus rien
tout ça c'est pareil et après le journal
télévisé j'ai été saisi d'une bourde ou
des passagers bien vu le mourousi il a
eu une petite mine oh là là des millions
de gens qui crèvent de faim je me suis
je peux pas rester immobile devant ce
spectacle
il faut que je fasse quelque chose il
faut faire je suis allé au restaurant je
m'en suis foutu plane alors j'ai
commencé par une soupe de courge attend
on a eu une petite terrine à base de
têtes de veau mélangé avec du pied de
cochon très fin
du gras double j'en ai repris deux fois
le toit rose et d'un seau terme un peu
d'où un peu trop doux mais enfin les
temps sont durs
voilà fait pas la peine de faire du
scandale alors qu'au bangladesh
j'ai enchaîné avec une cassolette de
queues d'écrevisses au lard ça c'était
les entrées comme viande
j'hésitais entre une oie braisé au sein
de canard et un porcelet à la gelée de
groseille le maître d'hôtel m'a dit et
je vous donnais de vous chipotez dans
les plats comme chez nous mais pour vous
et alors le plateau de fromages à
l'échauffement ce qui est un peu
d'honnêteté un peu dit stop ça suffit
je me réserve pour le dessert on va
présenter la ronde des desserts
jamais un tel cas phare que je me suis
tapé de tous je me suis mis jusque là
j'ai dit oh mais de tels arrêtés comme
on dit vulgairement j'ai les dents du
fond qui baigne d'ailleurs à la face ça
n'a pas loupé j'ai tout vomi
la contrariété
alors la légion étrangère ya à la popote
j'aimerais toucher rapidement à la botte
oui à la pâte
ce cône matam j'écoute j'écoute
ouais je vous ai parlé à raymond
je voudrais parler aurait mots c'est moi
même c'était le sujet ben oui si ça je
vois pas la jeune femme avec l'arrogance
a un pois bleus ouais lotois j'étais
tellement bourré ça va tu me manques tu
me manques et moi je te manque
bah ouais ouais non légionnaires voilà
bien un viol et un tu parles j'avais
ouais rien je t'adore
en tout cas dit et et merci pour le
petit cadeau mais petit cadeau le fric
que j'ai trouvé d'un magot des merci aux
tétouan mais non c'est chouette si tout
le monde était comme vous ça vaudrait la
peine
bon mais tout de même c'est chouette ce
qui compte c'est que je puisse tentant
perdants on te dit ce qui compte c'est
que je puisse entendre ta voix séoudiens
je répondrais ptj pas compris
jeudi l'important c'est que nous
puissions nous entendre sur les prix
alors oui ça me consoler un peu de
pouvoir téléphoner fait ça dérange pas
est ce que c'est que je pourrais pas au
cou géante agepe tête à m'occuper sera
pas une seconde je te prends mais
simplement je voulais appeler avant de
partir je m'envole pour paris dans une
heure à l'avancé pour - qui dans paris
oui j'ai embrassé paris 7 où 1
jeudi c'est tout ce que tu as à me dire
bah ouais
et puis merci pourquoi le petit cadeau
oui tu as bu un abus bah ouais vous voir
madame on se reverra plus répond ouais
c'est un peu de chance de ce soir nous
n'étions pas destiné à nous rencontrer
marqué notre cas c'était plutôt le genre
brève rencontre callebaut films
téléfilms brève rencontre à turin
mohamed m athieu répond mais moi je vous
prêter
saleh je suis content j'ai décroché la
faire enfin quand je dis je j'exagère
mon agence de publicité publique
pour resituer c'est nous qui avons lancé
les semelles cryptex et l'année d'après
elle éclipse mais l'ex menace sur ce
coup-ci attention n'était pas tout seul
le procès dit une campagne électorale
y aller tout le monde ils y étaient tous
il y avait havas et publicis
il y avait l'autre là qui a fait la
campagne de mitterrand
c'est pas dire son nom parce que j'ai
pas faire de la réclame à la concurrence
résultat des courses c'est moi qui ai
décroché la timbale aller rouler alors
le candidat sauna je peux pas vous dire
parce que justement première chose je
vais le faire changer de nom ils t'ont
marqué depuis 25 ans il est passé de
gauche à droite de droite à gauche au
centre à droite à gauche
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas des bons
documents sur lui sur toutes les photos
il bouge mon idée très branché très
ouais c'est d'essayer de trouver un an
mais si les familles sont se décider de
racheter un an oui
achetez pas trouver acheter pendant que
marie christine barrault répéter la moi
j'étais dans la coulisse attend que ce
soit mon tour je m'amuse mais c'est
complètement brechtien à l'arrêt du coup
il allume la lumière là bas j'arrête mon
jeu mais je rallume la lumière avait
dans ses filets en coupe ont atteint et
c'est ça la vie oui j'ai eu un trou de
mémoire quoi et alors on étale
intelligents et généreux
mon idée très branché très beau et c'est
d'essayer de racheter un nom oui si les
familles sont d'accord dont le
propriétaire d'origine est mort mais
dans le nom garde encore un crédit
énorme sur le puits
laval
la bloom
franco choses comme ça quand vous
achetez de la fine napoléon
l'argent ne va plus dans la poche de
napoléon c'est un de moins que pdg qui a
repris le nom
et quand un homme merveilleux comme
monsieur paul ricard va passer la main
ça sera plus lui mais son nom servira de
caution pour ben hur et des générations
et des générations
mais enfin en attendant il ya du travail
il ya du travail
le regard à télévision on change rien
comme il me dit vous m'apportez votre
pragmatisme je vous apporte mon
strabisme la france au fond des yeux ça
n'a pas marché lui la regarde à côté
d'une au sud-ouest homos à l'étagé bravo
très bien rien dire mais son élocution
ils votent et parle comme ça l'autre
jour je suis allée mettant lui est bien
devant 2000 personnes là le sonn la
scission au stand l'opposition
l'opposition ne doit pas fait son fils
ans
arrête je meurs assez fait sauter toutes
les dates comme et je vous aime et que
déjà en ordre pour rassurer les
épargnants sens avec l'été les riches
j'ai demandé aussi de changer de femme
il veut pas elle m'énerve elle et
luminaires elles pensent comme ni elle
dit alors quand on recevra la visite de
monsieur ronald reagan
tu fais une pige maalot à la grenobloise
qu'est ce que je pourrais lui faire des
ennemis ni haine sur les habits et la
coiffure je la ridiculise chemin
grotesque achevé la carnaval vise je
vais changer la couleur de ses cheveux
on a obtenu une couleur je vous dis pas
c'est pathétique
je commence mes affiches réponse absente
parce que mon idole affiche c'est vous
avez un village typiquement français le
ciel derrière et devant au premier plat
personnes non maudit et à la plage on
écrit en grosses lettres majuscules lui
il est déjà au travail
quand je vais au président quand même qu
est ce qu on dit dans les slogans que
vous êtes de gauche de droite je
m'excuse hymne dimanche les plus drôles
aussi je le dis je perd automatiquement
50% des voix
attention le professionnel rom et les
fiches anna et oui oui c'est là que
franchement j'étais génial d'ailleurs il
m'a téléphoné après il m'a dit
heureusement je vous embrasse
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir remarquer
que la droite dit partout que la gauche
accumule les maladresses
je vous dit rien vous avez un talent de
sogreah à partir de lundi sur toutes les
radios
c'est sa voix à le liquider
votez pour moi pour une gauche à droite
si un truc qui vaut mieux éviter
si on veut pas tomber malade c'est de
compulser un dictionnaire médical parce
que là si vous êtes tant soit peu
impressionnable
c'était un tout petit peu émotif toi ce
que tu lis tu l'as mois dépasse
néanmoins cédé pour ma fille est la
cadette le lot qui nous attraper des
boutons et oui on n'a qu'à nous fait
déboutant le lot et quand je dis bouton
je pense plutôt but on s'est même le
gros buffon qui s'était enfui ça serait
plus près de la crise que la myrtille
voix pour faire image c'est là la patte
peau enfin si mais vilaine déjà que bon
c'est ma fille mes objectifs voit quand
même pauvre cocotte peuvent le lot on
peut pas dire qu'elle soit vraiment nom
est sympathique et attachante mais alors
là ça lui fait déjouer deux tranches de
cake est gratos ans c'est dégueulasse
allez brandir de foie de veau vachement
appétissant alors on est allé voir un
dermatologue
hilary sculpté de partout temps en temps
je détourne et gpu dégobiller dessus ils
sont costauds des types ça vaut la peine
de faire des études
enfin il a regardé quand même ce qui
déjà sympa de sa part et aux résultats
eh ben il sait pas voilà il voit pas
bien il faut qu'il réfléchisse trois
docteurs mais c'est beaucoup comme je
vous dois voyez mon assistante 20 sacs
10 dont il y en a qui veulent pas leur
pognon enfin on sait tous que c'est pas
c'est pas le plus à risque où je peux
quoi je serai jamais le dire c'est pas à
l'hérésie ped ça on est sûr c'est pas
l'érythème parce que les rites elle
s'est plutôt fessiers et un appart ou 7
dégoûtante
ça n'est pas non plus une quelconque ni
causes ni qwam qes ça serait peut-être
sans engagement d'aucune par une pirate
aux primaires purulente
bénigne voilà on est content alors j'ai
regardé dans le dico cas kératoses
affection bénigne en effet se présente
en plus comme un état de la peau qu'une
maladie à part entière ça va au-delà
c'est pas une maladie c'est pour ça que
ça soit une transmission héréditaire
héréditaire probable rencontrer dès
l'enfance
ça c'est sa mère qui lui refiler des
salles chez nous dans ma famille
kératoses on n'a pas ça nous j'ai
demandé à tout le monde à mes parents
mon pépé a même émis on n'a pas ces
pannes ou bien deux c'est tout ça c'est
dégueulasse évolution débute le plus
souvent dans l'enfance oui et peut subir
une accentuation des signes lors de la
puberté
c'est là elle est encore petit yacht
mais avait été ce qu'ils le lot de
jeunes filles bien nous aider à le
prouver à fiancer ça on pourra toujours
mettre une annonce dans des stations
thermales y aura bien un eczéma de
passage qui sera intéressé cet âge là
c'est bien connu ça les démange les
petits bourgs à la vache chez la femme
fréquence d'une guérison spontanée à
l'âge mûr
de quoi je me plais petites bonnes comme
on vient de fêter ses cinq ans en avril
dernier à se gratter la couenne jusqu'à
sa ménopause
c'est les 40 premières années qui sont
les plus durs d'ici là pour son
anniversaire on lui a offert à les
moufles ils ont rien prévu sur
l'euthanasie place de l'édition bien
dans ces missionnaires vachement
encourageant rassurant je viens moi
quand je dis ça j'ai tout et puis on
écoute des tas de trucs la langue noir
jantes pas je n'en sais rien définition
hyper profit des papilles filiforme de
la partie postérieure de la langue celle
ci devienne grises ou noires at à la
vache on est peu de chose
l'affection indolore ah ben ça fait pas
mal c'est déjà ça
origine inconnue et dont le titre et il
se réveille matin il a la langue noir
personne ne sait d'où ça vient
on peut qu'ils soient catholiques
pratiquants et des communes il passe pas
inaperçu le mec on agissait la communion
c'est plus comme avant que tu as pu nous
montrer train le curé est un petit
chignon tu te bouffe dans un coup en
passant encore de dieu autant aller à la
boulangerie tu as une chose ardue pas
fret
normal la galerie de tomber sur un conte
que tu fais remarquer que tu as du noir
sont alors
la longue noire à la vache si je me
doutais que ça existait des machins
pareil alors traitement de points au cac
mais comme ça au moins c'est clair ça
c'est fois le type qui sait pas d'où ça
lui vient les apports pas au nettoyage
du nord allô docteur g la langue noir et
ben monsieur c'est votre problème
les goûts et les couleurs moi je suis
marié avec une japonaise et jean-paul
angot noir les assyriens parce qu'on
peut toujours su séduisant pour donner
le change mais alletru dans ce bouquin
tum intestines cullers ça c'est pas mal
non plus s'observe à tout âge les formes
maligne sont parfois faits militante et
peuvent donner des tests biologiques de
la grossesse positif dire que ce coup là
le type non seulement ils sont tous avec
les baloches comme des paupiettes mais
en plus sur les noms ce filet en cloque
j'espère que le suit l'accouchement sans
douleur au type
c'est tout ce qu'on voit l'once navires
et barges pour attraper au lasso je me
mets à courir partout dans les couleurs
de lost on the sand frappe encore avec
une plume dans le cul ah bah moi c'est
plutôt engueuler mais quelle horreur
mais qui alors horaire mais comment il
faut tous ces médecins pour supporter
tout ça tous les jours ça je me le
demande souvent parce que si c'est dans
le livre il est gros et la planète comme
ça et c'est fait pour des gens qui
savent donc ça arrive dans la vie tous
les jours comment ils font faut voir
moral surtout dans certains secteurs
le type qui se spécialise dans une
maladie qui se dit pas
moi je pourrais pas
tu sais je suis là je fait l'intéressant
gens racontent le dictionnaire médical
mais j'ai horreur de ce genre décoration
horaire aurait parce que il faut que je
vous fasse un aveu mois rien que d'en
parler
la maladie ça me tue
bonne fête polaire vais lui dire à ma
femme
bonne fête paulette et je lui donnerais
mon bouquet elle a horreur des fleurs
c'est justement je déteste ma femme
alors je vois pas pourquoi je lui aurait
offert des chocolats
paulette adore les chocolats moi j'aime
ou pas pour l'être alors soyons logiques
et pourtant bien précisé à ma mère je
leur ai dit je veux pas épousé paul est
elle m'a répondu on parle pas à table
bon mon père non plus les pauvres fous
fous de ma mère mais lui trente ans de
mariage
il a fait le plus gros le jour je
regarde ses jambes jeudi tête et bugs
qui plissent blanc aime retourne une
claque elle avait pas de bas j'ai dit à
ma mère paulette est moche même répond
paulette me ressemble je dis oui mais
toi tu es ma mère elle me répond pour
être pourrait être ta mère
bon alors des fleurs elle va faire une
société où j'aime pas sa tête à les
mettre à la poubelle aux primes sont les
fleurs surtout les grands mais ça fait
pas plus de profit que les sites
allez jeter c'est sûr je m'en fiche les
ai achetés avec l'argent des commissions
qui remonte mois des escalopes j'ai
horreur des escalopes se dégoûte
elle semblait sur la figure c'est un
rêve que pour sortir au prix où sont les
escalopes c'est que leveaux s'est pas
donné un jeu la figure dans un sens si
j'avais épousé une beauté je m'ennuie à
il paraît que les mannequins les
actrices c'est très ennuyeux surtout le
jour moi j'aime bien engagé la
conversation pourleth elle parle elle
dit des bêtises beaucoup de bêtises
c'est normal parce qu'elle est bête
sa pratique parce que je comprends pas
ce qu'elle dit c'est les les filles
intellectuelle faut pas croire c'est la
barbe est sorti de l'intelligence et de
la culture
elles ont pas à grand chose peut-être
une bonne fête paulette ça m'énerve que
je l'appelle poulet tel concert commun
son vrai nom c'est germaine je l'appelle
paulette pour lui rabaissé son caquet
véritable soupe au lait n'empêche que si
je m'écoutais il ya des soirs je l'aï
dit aux villageois yolngu il a coupé en
petits morceaux et on trouverait jamais
son kata s'annonce assez dans le journal
avec sa photo alors écoutez le seul
plaisir de ma journée c'est prendre mon
petit crème le matin tranquille à la
terrasse de chez lui
en lisant mon petit journal alors si
c'est pour retrouver les photos de
paulette en première page
bonne fête follett
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont belles ces nanas
à la vache
elles sont belles à les [ __ ] ça
oh [ __ ] ça mais pas son téléphone sous
la photo cette pêche comisca des frais
pour venir l'aider à rude pression
blaugies est drôlement usagers semblent
eux gina je vais pas critiquer mais
c'est pas une première massa [ __ ] de
dessin non là c'est servan-schreiber
qu'est ce qu'il fout là jusqu'au bout et
a exigé ss jusqu'au bout il ya quand
même pesté le quai jjss non ce serait
chouette comme argument électoral
radical j'ai tous les gus qui viennent à
défier les sous de la politique par ge
et ti chirac giscard d'estaing d'en
soulever de mon petit accordéon d'urines
surprise et ainsi de suite et c'est ça
être patrice 521 jusqu'au bout et jg
c'est sûr dit quand même j'aime mieux
aller jusqu'au bout avec ma copine au
blue jeans où elle est ma copine où elle
est vrai que la revoilà aulas elle a
garé son panty ou kaki
à puce à qui ça c'est chouette c'est
futé ceux qui font ça le magazine de
l'homme moderne cd futé ils sont futés
il mélange tout jjss nadia l'aris chat
jean paul sartre zaza sème la zizanie
c'est futé 1
ça m'arrange pour amener de la lecture à
la maison 1 tu être parce que les filles
les vraies celles qu'on peut toucher mon
cul oui c'est tous conquis cances
transparent muni d'une mini short les
humains cela nous ça n'aurait été
présentés police comme un enfant alors
qu mais dans la tête sont encore en
pinot lice
voilà
qu'est ce qui reste
josette on peut prendre la pilule pour
garder la ligne
c'était tellement d'efforts dans les
grossesses canton deux accouchements ou
même plus la différence
il faut lutter contre l'assouplissement
sexuelle il m'a dit le docteur je lui
docteur je lui tire alava gpu c'est la
salle alors
cet après midi j'étais à l' usine mon
usine et je regardais la france à
travers la vitre savez ce genre de
vitres là je peux comment ça s'appelle
en sécurité pour pâques un imbécile
il me balancer un boulon dedans il nous
la [ __ ] en l'air
j'étais encore sous le choc
une scène très pénible avec les délégués
syndicaux
je leur ai dit vous les clefs oui vous
les nîmois la cij avait pas dit poisson
d'avril au dernier moment ils les
piquets
mon frère est entré avec son beau visage
buriné par le farniente
je dis comment ça va tu es yeux parce
qu'il s'était fait des ampoules aux
paupières
à force de dormir
regardez tous les deux la foule des
ouvriers qui s'écoulait de la sortie 830
personnes quand même plus 80 noir
et 120 femmes total un millier de
personnes un millier de salaire je
sentais son odeur de vétiver derrière
moi il m'a dit de savoir caverneuse
bientôt plus personne n'aura plus rien
plus un lyon plus un club de golf +1
vanguard rien ou lamento france ouf nous
mène-t-il pour moi j'ai mon dossier des
impôts là on me reproche mais chevaux de
course mais je suis la vraie un cheval
de course ça bect moins qu'une
secrétaire et nous en parlions avec les
autres la société d'encouragement de la
race chevaline
mais la race chevaline elle va
décourager mon yacht mon yacht 40 mètres
de long
quatre moteurs six marins
je vous passe l'urssaf mais vous savez
ce qu'on fait avec mon yacht ou longe le
bord du port de cannes parce que mon
épouse moeurs de peur repas une femme
malade
le climat social lui donne de l'asthme
son seul dérivatif c'est de rajeunir
secret nuit et jour
moralité en trois ans à la radio ni
d'une heure
on longe le bord ont fait des huit à
l'intérieur du port et on revient au
mouillage mais s'appuie stick qui ont
gènes qui ont gêne comme fait une fois
que j'entends ça pour quoi vous servez
vous d'un avion privé
parce que je n'irai attendant on avions
ps ils me prennent dessus je mens pas
non non j'étais obligé de dire à mon
personnel je ne peux pas vous garder je
ne peux pas à la campagne on avait une
paire d'émigrés enfin bart équivalent
sur 10 un couple d'émigrés immigrés
alors lâchez pas comment il faut dire ça
sent comme dit mon épouse on sait pas où
ils vont d'où ils viennent alors
immigrés et muret servions même derrière
eux mêmes au demeurant des gens discrets
ils ont accepté un salaire pour deux
ailes elle tient la maison elle fait la
cuisine lui il est logé dans son lit et
en échangeant les demandes d'aidés un
peu au jardinage à la maçonnerie
l'entretien de la ferme
au gardiennage de nuit il conduit la
voiture
il a réparé quand elle est en panne
on a trois rugissent on occupe
ils coupent les arbres bon je leur fais
une salle de bain qu'est ce qu'ils me
foutent de d'un du charbon charbon ma
mère et moi non plus c'est moi qui me
fais graf et par l'inspection du travail
ou les vous qui m est charmant puisqu'il
avait visé la salle de bains de la cad
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau ça
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau
attendant la mise en place
mais ce qu'il fait je mens pas mais bon
donc là et tous les sans emploi je crée
l'autre jour un de mes livres y y et
diane de villandry se prend une épine
dans une pâte
voilà 180 à l'heure à ferrari pour
foncer chez le vétérinaire au croisement
je m'en vais la faune tracteur bien j'ai
continué j'avais rien voyage avait quand
même mon aileron arrière droit
spécialement accord aussi en italie par
le couturier giovanni tortelli qui
carrosse mais voiture et ma femme
n'aideront arracher cette union s'en
fout mais derrière moi le paysan bassin
fracturé gendarmerie ambulanciers
brancardier deux motards pour le chemin
ils croisent les pompiers parce que le
tracteur s'était renversée incendies
dans les cultures
affolement à l'hôpital mais
saperlipopette je vais travailler toute
une région
je fais travailler toute une région
alors le 1 % voient la sécurité sociale
par exemple je suis allé voir mon
contrôleur des contributions et je lui
dis simplement combien gagnez vous
combien gagnez-vous il répond temps je
lui dis eh bien le 1 % comme le réclame
sur mon revenu représente cette fois
votre salaire
il est resté de marbre alors j'étais
obligé de dire ma femme je ne peux plus
te garder je ne peux plus
l'état me prends tous qu ils te prennent
aussi qui se chargent de toi ma poule
jeu de nationalise non partir changer
d'horizon demain de coutume de racine
partir loin pour se faire naturaliser
il faut remplir un formulaire 1 pour
quel pays
optez vous deux pour quelles raisons
alors j'ai rempli et j'attendais un
monaco
2 pour la vue
dans la convention s'il vous plaît les
passagers du vol air france
numéro 320 à destination de marrakech
sont informés et ceci afin d'éviter
désormais tout à l'entente du que le
texte qui va leur être présentées
maintenant et d'inspiration anti raciste
merci marrakech
ça nous a déçus natha nous a pas plu
c'est plein de table pourtant nous on
navigue vers clichy il y en a des arabes
à mai à marrakech
y'a que ça non déjà l'avion pour y aller
ça nous avait pas fait bonne impression
c'est pas ta la question de la violence
l avion communal et un congrès de
l'entreprise il avait plutôt bien fait
les choses
un petit avion ring pour nous les
collègues de l'entreprise bien aucune
promiscuité bien mais ses katas de vue
arriver l'aviateur ou quel malheur vous
n'avez pas qu'est-ce qui vous avez
trouvé comme médiateur eh bien je dis à
ma moitié ça commence bien
ma pauvre simone d'un couac on sait
encore embarqué qu'elles ont dès lors
qu'elle a rappelé très à l'aise pas gêné
du tout du tout - arabe
je me suis dit faisons tout petits dés
fois qu'on marquait pas et je pars c'est
géraud de base c'est à dire et je veux
pas vad
c'est moi que je suis le maître à bord
visé moi un peu les gars là je tripote
les manettes et les petits boutons comme
si j'aurais fait ça depuis toujours
comme ça dans mes ancêtres personne
n'aurait jamais carnet une chèvre de
famille
ils ont pris à toulouse renouent avec
les collègues on me faisait pas on est
des touristes le comedd incident il
roulait à mettre benoît ou led nous
souhaite la bienvenue à bord très bien
parfait c'est pas le faire des remarques
l'armée française n'a pas fait un seul
canal ces plumages dit à monsieur cadori
qui était à côté à voir comment avec le
service marque en guise de dot s et de
bonbons il vous nous voyez une gamme d
olive des cacahuètes mais sur la natte
en quelque chose de pas catholique en
est à noter sur pied en 2005 tueur
d'ailleurs c'est l'autre la l'aviateur
arabe lui même qui nous a demandé de les
attacher et ce qu'elle tombe
mesdames et messieurs vous êtes priés
d'attaché vos ceintures et des tonnes de
cigarettes rang quelle arrogance
je suis pas si la sortie de cet appareil
le surdo réprobation ou quoi n'empêche
que plein de tout le voyage les
incidents donc pas cessé de se
multiplier ou ceux qui adorent évite la
relig omar volontairement pour nous est
de la serbie
déjà ils ont fait excuser quelques
palmiers les passagers qui pourraient me
passer un beat palaze à la fin que je
fasse mes calculs sinon on peut pas
décoller ça fait sérieux
moi j'avais mon waterman a plu même corp
aurait plaqué or que simone m'a offert
pour ma nomination à la direction du
service national meilleur accès que ces
gens là ne décrivent pas du tout comme
les autres au ps et que les écrits de
droite à gauche reçoit terme un niveau
complètement de saloperies comme si vous
leur a quand il volera
on commande de prétendre après que soi
disant ils auraient été égarés meute
waterman la plume est vrai cadeau de
schiphol oui mais oui d'ailleurs les
connais moi c'est spacieux l'a
finalement c'est monsieur k d'or et il
s'est dévoué qui a passé sur ce stylo
mines et nous avons pu nous en veulent
et mektoub le seigneur sauter pendant
toute la traversée il a pas arrêté de se
faire remarquer ma main c'était un peu
assoupie avec les collègues mais
l'intense chaleur qui régnait dans la
carlingue hilaire qui commençait sur la
chaîne info mon ami on est tous
réveillés en sursaut c'était encore lui
lot l'indigène qui criait saint soit
honnête je lève où ça sent le brûlé les
hommes voyager dans ces conditions faire
renifler comme des cockers dans la
travée dit tout bas monsieur cadors il
s'amuse avec nous quoi tu adores est
très fin psychologue me dit il s'amuse
très bien parfait amusons-nous la france
est à quatre pattes est tout à fait dans
le sens de l'histoire
le maréchal lyautey et moi nous nous
inclinons juste après il se met à hurler
dans son micro comme un hystérique
alors là tout est comme toile alors la
cour des comptes le voulez vous me dire
où je me tenais si en plus je n'en ai
pas la moindre idée
une vierge d'installer ans on apprit
adoré 10h02 coup j'étais au bord de tous
les deux la mienne la simone n'était pas
non plus très belle à voir
rabat dites-vous en écho jeudi bouge pas
six mois ne pousse pas de toute passion
chez un copain lui qui est responsable
n'importe quel terminal si l'avion tome
7 et 10 ans dans leurs torts nissan a
fini par se poser c'est déjà quelque
chose
or là partout des arabes des arabes des
arabes que ça que sa caisse à les porter
bon ça normal
les douaniers un des policiers a le
droit à la vie une fois vos actualités
sas prime très correctement il a l'air
de très bonne famille grecque nationale
oui ils sont chez eux encore lui le roi
l'autre la loi il est pas mal ce garçon
il est pas mal attention ils leur tient
la dragée haute à tous ces va nu pieds
je me demande si l'ap un peu de san
francisco la fois qu'il reçoit jeudi à
simone c'est la dernière fois qu'on met
les pieds on colonies il faut pas me
dire ah si c'était à nous dans
l'entreprise nous employons énormément
de travail en or africain
eh bien nous les avons laissé installer
leur village leur espèce depuis
deauville la touques chantier lephone
des coûts de pouvoir de la maison
monsieur bourdieu qui est un homme pas
libéral plutôt à gauche arrivait un jour
au bureau complètement retourné en usage
de passer en voiture près des
baraquements nord africains il faut
absolument faire quelque chose pour ces
malheureux ne pourront pas se leurrer
une par une misère
en plus ça se voit de la route c'est
très fâcheuses pour le standing de la
maison eh bien nous nous sommes réunis
un comité nous avons voté des crédits
croyez moi vous pouvez passer en voiture
près de chez nous vous verrez plus rien
de tout ça ils ont fait construire un
mur